hi I'm RIA and this is my recipe for old
crab cake so a few years ago there was a
trend where you roll up apple slices
onto a pastry and made a little turret
so I was wondering if there was anything
I could make that would look pretty like
that and I came up with this idea using
crepes instead of Pesce I wasn't sure if
it's gonna walk first but I tried it
anyways and when I think of crepes my
favorite feeling it's strawberry and
whipped cream so instead of apples I
decided to use strawberries the
important thing about making crepes is
wasted dough for at least 30 minutes
because we are mixing with milk and
flour which creates gluten and if you
don't want to make chewy and rubbery
crepes if you want you can also rest in
overnight and make it the next day
I chose cream cheese filling because
it's a little thicker so easy to work
with you are ending up making a bunch of
crepes for this recipe and that will
take time but I also think it's fun as
well so I tested this and made a pretty
small version that was really really
cute but when I make the tart I usually
want to share so I don't want to make it
just for myself when you're making at
home it's a little bit messy because
you're spreading cream onto the crepe
and rolling it up but it's what's there
for and most a man because it's really
pretty and I'm sure whoever you're going
to give it to will be super impressed
make sure to cut the strawberry it's
very thin it's similar to a crepe cake
because it's layered about just a
different presentation because the
crepes are vertical instead of fries on
top
so instead of stopping making small
little tart I was just kept rolling and
rolling and rolling and I ended up
making a large crepe cake
I think rolling it up it's the most fun
and difficult particles it's kind of
like building a snowman it's the same
cake all the way through it just gets
bigger also after you make this roll the
crepe a big enough then you can start
laying it on the side instead of rolling
then what you end up with it's a super
pretty roll of crepes all standing up
with strawberry it's kind of looking
like a flower which is why I call this a
rose crepe cake this is the perfect
dessert to bring down afternoon people
ready or just to make reads your friends
sometime I was filming this recipe late
and I because I wasn't sure if it's
gonna work so I was kind of testing and
shooting at the same time and Alex and
Scott was also shooting Leigh and I so
we shared together and both of them are
super impressed so this recipe it's
something I'm really proud of because
I've never seen this type of cake before
so I would like you to make it and I
also want you to proud of it
thank you for watching see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you